thank you very much members of the
Academy first I have to thank my father
my father this is for my father that we
did it I want to thank my daughter for
telling me just before I got up here if
you don't win dad you're still good
thank you to my dad for everything he
taught me do you dad you taught me what
it means to be a man I want to thank my
father up there you know my dad didn't
get to see me do any of this stuff I
think he's looking down on me right now
my dad always say son you get so many
movie a war in the world whether you get
one of this dad you're the greatest
thank you for showing me that there is
honor in looking back and respecting the
past when you give me this award you
honor my father calls over you know who
has taught me everything I know about
acting I love you very much dad when I
was 8 years old I was called into the
principal's office and my father was
looking very seldom and he said we got
to go it's grandma we got in the car and
I said what's wrong with Grandma he said
nothing we're going to the movies